[Music]
bob saget has died he was 65 years old
as a comic my whole thing was to be
funny and the key is to try to be you
know talented and funny and you can tell
right now i'm being incredibly whimsical
the orange county sheriff's office in
florida confirmed the news on sunday
stating saget was found unresponsive in
a hotel room and pronounced deceased at
the scene the office added no signs of
foul play or drug use were discovered
the sagitt family provided e.t with this
statement quote we are devastated to
confirm that our beloved bob passed away
today he was everything to us and we
want you to know how much he loved his
fans performing live and bringing people
from all walks of life together with
laughter
though we ask for privacy at this time
we invite you in joining us and
remembering the love and laughter that
bob brought to the world
sagat is survived by his wife kelly and
three daughters aubry lara and jennifer
stars have taken to social media to pay
tribute good friend and former full
house co-star john stamos wrote quote i
am broken i am gutted i am in complete
and utter shock i will never ever have
another friend like him i love you so
much bobby
candace cameron beret shared quote i
don't know what to say i have no words
bob was one of the best human beings
i've ever known in my life i loved him
so much
taj maori shared this image to his
instagram story he captioned the pic
quote r.i.p to one of the sweetest men i
have ever had a chance to know
the stand-up comedian shot to fame in
1987 as danny tanner on full house
often called one of tv's greatest dads
it's a father uh two guys that are and
all trying to raise these kids and the
youngest one is of course the most
difficult trying to change diapers and
things wow it's nice to see that my dad
talked the other morning had this much
impact on you
my dad talks never have this much impact
on me look at his camera but she's my tv
daughter saggett returned to his iconic
role for netflix's reboot series fuller
house
extra strong febreze three-ply paper
towel you're cleaning at housekeeper
level
et spoke with the late actor on his
final day of filming it's
meaningful because i was 30 years old
when i started the show which means
danny tanner was 21 when he had dj
and i was a string bean and candace
and jody and andrea
you know it's it's emotional and we love
each other and we've been friends all
these years
and we've been there for each other and
people have heard all this ad nauseam
but it's
it's honestly true i mean it's a it's an
extended family we've always loved each
other and that's what i think made the
show a success is it was in between the
lines that stuff that happens when it's
real between people and to see them
to become such beautiful
women and it's just it's just wonderful
to watch
[Music]
you